okay um next video
again this uh finnish international
master with lots of eyes in the name
ah king's camp it okay i'll take it
and now this line yeah okay
the usual continuation i would be knight
c3 and
then c6 e5
yeah the bad thing about the king's
gambit is always that um
very rarely you get it played against
you and then you have but
you know you forgot all the all the book
moves i think d5 is correct here
so as usual against e5 if you had to
spawn d5
um this is of course a very
messy position already
okay let's see
first impression would be that black is
doing great but
you never know in the king's camp it
okay let's do a quick um
count here i'm actually a pawn up
yeah i could i could go queen e7 to
exchange queens or
spoil his castling
king f2 is also not very attractive i
have
queen c5 check as well
sorry yeah
okay i guess i'll exchange queen at
least
you don't get mated then and now bishop
f5
looks very good attacking c2
yeah okay he can he can do that but
if he takes on c4 i'd have c2 always to
to compensate so i just go on quick
development
knight c6 and then probably long castle
and rookie eight this
looks very nice it's also still an extra
pawn
and this position actually looks like
you would sacrifice a pawn to to get
something like that
okay i take c2 of course d3 i'll just
cancel long and
d3 i think it's not not easy to defend
yeah this looks really really good for
black
i don't see a decent move here this was
of course possible
just long castling now and d4 is hanging
i don't see how it defends it actually
okay knight d4 check this just
if he takes rook d4 then e5 and c4 is
hanging
yeah looks great just don't waste
too much time
okay
i could also just take and
rook d4 again what does he do
after this move bishop e5 maybe
to rescue the peace
or i could take with the king also
yeah okay i don't want to waste too much
time
it's a good position anyway with an
extra pawn and
bishop pair only thing i need to
make sure of that i don't get any
problems on c7
which could happen after all
yeah i need to get this bishop back
somehow
maybe f5 there you go f5
to get the square e4 for the bishop
check
so now i could go bishop d4
yeah just
just play simple
you might retreat now with bishop e3 i
think
the moves look strange
93 but this is just a self pin
i could play c6 and i don't think it
would do him any good
okay he goes for the self pin
now b2 is also hanging
hg8 maybe to
activate a little bit and yeah well this
is
this is the exchange yeah yeah take it
okay just exchange server
announcement exchange everything down
now
yeah b6 to to keep the material
and i have always root d5 at some point
to
cover f5 this is the only weakness
now possibly rook e8 to e4 to
get very nice centralized rooks
and the next step could be to just push
the pawns
he also needs to look out for simple
things like rook d3 to trade everything
down
okay yeah maybe on rook e4 you now would
have
no he doesn't have g4 actually because
of rook d3
well then it's a good move i guess
and then i should try push my pawns a
bit here
after all i've got the extra pawn on the
queen side as well
also just a4s it's a good idea
need to take a little bit care about
time but
it's still
rather comfortable
yeah it's very nice that
both rooks are not are protected
so it's we really can't do can't do much
in this position
okay now f4
in order to get a new weakness on
b3
now i have to take care maybe it's going
for g4 so
i better also prevent that
okay time warning
just this one
d3
yeah but now after this i'll open the
bishop i think
don't i yeah
check
i think he just forgot the position of
the resign button
check check check
check
check
check
i've got 30 seconds so
i'm not the quickest player in the world
but
this really should be enough
checkmate yeah yeah this was just an
opening
disaster well i don't know if this is
some some viable line in any way with e5
but
at least this is just yeah maybe it's
close to winning already
extra pawn bishop pair and
also i'm quicker in developing my pieces
maybe it's better for him not to take
here but
but otherwise how does he develop his
pieces he can play b3
because of the strong bishop on g7 and
if he moves the d pawn it's just
another weakness on d3 i guess just just
lost of the opening
basically